nothing against you from earlier on when
you said you bleed your parents because
you were too sure there's a big thing
just now it's good to blame your parents
for everything you know I feel and in
some ways this is an awful thing you see
I'm sure in some ways because I lost my
parents when I was young it freed me
from that because I couldn't blame them
because they weren't there so I had my
one thing to deal with and so I couldn't
see you should have made me go soccer
more I would have been a great soccer
player if you had you know pushed me a
little I don't have that so I had to
save myself I should have played soccer
more you know I was my fault you know so
in an awful way it was freeing because
in the world that we live in where I
think people wait to blame the parents
for everything I didn't have that I was
left with myself you know I couldn't
blame my grandmother she was slowly
getting smaller and smaller but yeah you
know and everyone has their baggage you
know so I grew up in a council estate in
Scotland so I have that Scottish well
I'm Scottish oppress something about
that
you know I think nationalism isn't a
great thing I think it's lovely it's the
am Scott you should look at her great
history but don't be nationalists about
it you know I think that causes a lot of
problems in the world you know that my
country is better than yours so I kind
of watch that and then working-class is
another one that's a real sort of chip
on my shoulder that we've got you home
what Matt just we've got to kind of you
know defeat these and you you know you
put yourself in these groups and I think
these grips that you put yourself and
causes a lot of problems in your life so
the more you can kind of just try and
get rid of those grips and just kind of
go hey I'm sitting in this room with
these three guys and great guys this is
fun we're talking we're lessening the
more that the world can do that just
know I think the better boy when you
just Zone in and you're not we're not
goofing around I would just say
beautiful captivating yeah no I know it
sounds funny but I feel like I just
learned something it is in a
three-minute thing you just said I feel
like I'm listening and I'm going you
know you didn't have your parents to
blame it in a sense and I'm like and I
don't necessary blame my parents
I let things go and I love them but you
know in a sense I'm lucky that I had
that yeah so always be grateful always
just be grateful for whatever you had
because someone had it worse and this is
life and it's only gonna get worse or
better at times intermittently yeah and
like but it just it just put things into
perspective
yeah perspective is huge right yeah but
it's also another easy thing to see and
a difficult thing to do